>> I AM WORRIED RIGHT NOW.
TIME FOR LEFTOVERS, IT'S THE
ENEMY WEANING COOKIE SEGMENT I
STOLE FROM RACHAEL RAY.
I KID.
IT'S WHERE WE READ THE JOKES WE
DIDN'T USE THIS WEEK.
WITH ANY LEFTOVERS YOU NEVER
KNOW IT IF THEY'RE GOOD MENTALL
YOU TAKEN IT'S WAY FIRST TIME
READING THESE INTO A MEAN THAT.
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S FORKED
CONCERNS ABOUT HIS MENTAL
FITNESS AT A HEALTH EVENT
WEDNESDAY WHEN HE REPEATEDLY
CALLED OUT FOR A DECEASED
CONGRESSWOMAN THE WHITE HOUSE
CLARIFIED THAT WHEN HE ASKED
JACKIE ARE YOU HERE, HE MEANT
JACKIE KENNEDY.
>> THAT WAS GOOD.
>> OF FLORIDA TV REPORTER WAS
CRITICIZED FOR PUTTING A ON HER
MICROPHONE DURING HURRICANE
BROADCAST RATE SHE SAID AND KEP
THE MIC I'M GETTING DAMAGED WEL
THAT MIKE COMPLAINED THAT IT
COULDN'T FEEL ANYTHING AT ALL.
IN SPEECH AT THE KOREAN MILITAR
ZONE.
THEY REFERRED TO AMERICA AS
HAVING A LONG ALLIANCE WITH
NORTH KOREA.
THE VICE PRESIDENT BLAMED HER
CONFUSION ON THE LOCATION AS
IT'S THE FIRST TIME SHE'S EVER
BEEN TO A BORDER.
IN AN APPEARANCE, MICHAEL MOORE
PREDICTED A LIEN SITE IN
NOVEMBER, BUT HE WASN'T TALKING
ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS CHANCES,
THAT'S JUST WHAT HAPPENS WHEN H
GETS OUT OF BED.
FAMILIES OF VICTIMS OF JEFFREY
DAHMER ARE COMPLAINING ABOUT TH
NEW MARY NEW SERIES ON NETFLIX
FREIGHT IT WAS ORIGINALLY
SCHEDULED FOR THE FOOD NETWORK.
WHAT CAN THEY COMPLAIN ABOUT?
NEW YORK CITY'S RESIDENTS UPSET
OVER THE MAYOR'S PLANS FOR
MIGRANT TENT CITY.
ON THE RIGHT SIDE, AT LEAST
JULIE WILL HAVE A PLACE TO PASS
OUT AFTER HAPPY HOUR.
IT'S FUNNY BECAUSE IT'S TRUE.
WE DEAL IN INDIA LIVED WITH HER
HUSBAND'S CORPSE FOR 18 MONTHS
ANGEL WAS UNAWARE HE DIED
DOCTORS VALIDATED HIS CLAIM CNG
WAS RESPONDING AT THE LEVEL OF
MOST MARRIED MEN.
YOU TRY BEING MARRIED TO WOMEN,
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY CALL IT
CAPS HAD THE HONOR OF PLAYING
JAMES MADISON'S 200 -YEAR-OLD
CRYSTAL FLUTE DURING HER
WASHINGTON, D.C. CONCERT ALREAD
DYNAMIC ARTIST, SHE NOW ALSO TH
PIED PIPER OF POT PIES.
I GUESS I'M HAPPY IT COULD HAVE
GONE IN A BAD DIRECTION.
THE AVERAGE PERSON BEGINS TO
WORRY ABOUT THEIR VISION AT AGE
39 EXCEPT FOR FEEL HIS WIFE HE
SAID BLINDNESS CAN'T COME SOON
ENOUGH.
THEY ANNOUNCED THEY HAD THEIR
SEVENTH CHILD THIS WEEK, ALEC
FOUND OUT THE HARD WAY, HE
WASN'T SHOOTING BLANKS.
I SAW THAT ONE COMING.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ANNOUNCED A NEW RULE THAT WOULD
REQUIRE AIRLINES DIDN'T TRAVEL
SITES TO INCLUDE ALL FEES AND
TICKET PRICES.
THIS PROPOSAL IS PROPOSED BY
EVERY MAJOR LEGITIMATE AIRLINE
AND ALSO SPIRIT AIR.
FINALLY, A STUDY OUT OF NEW
MEXICO FUNDAMENT WITH BIGGER AR
PERCEIVED AS MORE OUTGOING TO
WHICH I'LL ADD, HOW IS IT GOING
MY FRIEND?
THANKS FOR JOINING US, LET'S DO
IT AGAIN.
I FEEL I'M AMBIVALENT ABOUT